good evening committee members
visiting councillors members of the
public
welcome to the planning policy committee
i will now read out the emergency
evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building
would you please leave the building by
the rear doors of this hall
turn right and go through two sets of
double doors to the car park
which is the assembly point please do
not delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so
by council staff please note this
meeting will be audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silence
members there are four microphones on
the tables
for use during the meeting when you are
invited to speak please wait till
this microphone in front of you has been
switched on before speaking as the
microphone needs to be hearing loop
and for the audio recording where
possible please help by passing
microphones
to each other and use the hand gel and
antibacterial wipes
on the table if you do touch the
microphones members
voting will be done on the show of hands
in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
then against the recommendations
numbers will be noted by the officers
before we get to the agenda proper just
can i just explain to
our visiting councillors uh mr goodwin
will make the presentation of each
section of the agenda if you have any
questions
if it's possible can you wait until he
finishes his presentation on each item
because sometimes you may have a
question and he will actually be
addressing it further down
his report can i just elaborate a little
bit
you may not agree with a lot of the
ideas on some of these evidential
documents
but we need to be seen to have
considered all aspects
when making our final presentation to
the inspectorate and we have found
of late that some councils have lost
down
because they have not gone down that
route and have
just discussed two preferred options for
example so
some of these items will not be perhaps
in accordance we've watched the district
council
policies but they do have to be
considered in the light of the evidence
to be presented
okay uh i think that's it
uh we will now move on to the agenda
proper
apologies for absence we have none
non-members attending we believe have
councillors
mrs gooding this is gadsden council
award
thank you minutes of the meeting held on
the 7th of january 2021
i hope members have had the opportunity
to read that if you're in an agreement
can i sign those in due course i agree
please everybody
well for those that you weren't for
those that were at a meeting
are we in agreement thank you i will i
will sign them okay
oops um
item number four to receive any
declarations of interest
okay item number five over to you mr
goodwin
thank you chairman so item number five
is the new local plan spatial options
consultation paper
so this is the second stage in the
preparation of the council's new local
plan
members may remember that we consulted
on an issue and options document
in early 2018 the assistant options
document set out a range of challenges
and opportunities
about how planning issues could be
addressed in the local plan
so this is the next stage in that
process so it's about refining the
options available to the council
it's about weighing up the merits of
different options and
ultimately going out to consultation so
that
interested parties can make
representations on those
options
what i would say is it's a fairly
lengthy document it's
split out into sections it
first considers what the council's
vision should be for the district
alongside some objectives it considers
emerging strategy options relating to
the scale and distribution of future
development
it then goes through a number of spatial
themes
which will all contribute to achieving
that vision
and finally it goes through individual
settlements in the district and
considers
their individual needs individual
visions and provides an opportunity for
interested people to comment on specific
options relating to that settlement
so as i say it's a fairly detailed
document
it obviously sets out a lot of different
options
and is structured around a number of
questions which obviously
give interested people an opportunity to
provide feedback on those options
so the recommendation before the
committee is that this document goes out
to public consultation
we are required to consult for a minimum
of six weeks um
and if agreed it's likely that that
consultation would commence
uh either monday the 19th of july or
possibly monday the 26th of july to be
confirmed and alongside that item there
is a consultation strategy at appendix c
this sets out broadly how the council
would consult on that consultation
um how it would engage interested
members of the public alongside other
stakeholders
and as i say sets out a minimum
to be compliant with the council
statement of community involvement
it is in the council's gift to go beyond
what's in that consultation strategy
but as mentioned at a recent working
group meeting
um the issue of whether face-to-face
meetings can take place
will need to be subject to a risk
assessment and uh
take due record of uh the concert
uh coronavirus regulations that are in
place at that time
uh so um as i say the the
recommendation before the committee is
that this document appendix a is
consulted on for a period
of six weeks and that that consultation
is carried out in accordance with that
consultation strategy
we have also asked that authority be
delegated to
the assistant director for place
environment in consultation with the
portfolio holder
and the main reason for that is to be
able to address
any minor textual or cosmetic changes
um that are needed to make the document
accurate
and accessible at the time of
consultation so that could include
improved mapping um as well as improved
presentation overall
and that would obviously um allow us to
meet that date of the 19th or 26th of
july
so that's probably all i have to say on
that chairman but obviously
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you chairman um on page
5.3 3.9
digital and physical leaflets setting
out the key consultation information
including a qr code to the consultation
portal can
officer confirm that that will be a
leaflet to
every single household within the
district
and will those leaflets
be tailored to specific
areas and not just a generic
leaflet
i think this is a chairman if i just may
add to that well
well
thank you sorting right
please
you've been on the stage
personally chairman i don't think we
need it i think we can hear each other i
mean i could hear you
oh sorry sonia okay
are we good to go right
did you do you want to refresh on the
question mr goodwin or
are you happy with that i think i i
think i have the question yeah but can i
just
finish what i was just going to say that
at the issues and options stage a
leaflet went to
every single household so i think we
would be doing an injustice if we didn't
replicate that at this stage considering
this is probably
more stage okay so
um thank you for that for that question
i mean
the honest answer is that no at this
time
a leaflet to every household in the
district isn't planned
um you're right to say that at the issue
of knocking stage we did do that
and from memory i believe it costs
something in the region of about 15 000
pounds to do
that to i think 35 000 houses
um at the moment it's not budgeted for
that we
could do that it's it's obviously
possible to do that
it wouldn't require a lot of officer
resource but it obviously would require
a financial
resource that isn't currently budgeted
for
um i i can understand arguments both
both for and against
i mean just to reflect on the issue and
options consultation
we we obviously sent leaflets to 35 000
houses
but we only had something in the region
of 550 representations
so um whilst it may have raised
awareness it didn't
um ultimately lead to a to a higher
response rate
um but what i would say is you know i
think ultimately
it would probably be need to be a
decision for for council
if this committee wanted to recommend to
council that budget was made available
for that
because at this time the budget doesn't
exist for us to be able to do that and
i would estimate it would probably be in
the region of seventeen and a half
thousand probably allowing for for some
inflation
so um i mean what i would say and i
appreciate this is this isn't
directly your question but you know i
mean i have
strong confidence in the measures that
we are proposing that they would be
effective at
raising awareness possibly not as
directly as what you're proposing
but you know equally i suppose this has
been put together weighing up
the pros and cons in terms of both
response and
and resource and um value for money in
that in that sense
so i think chairman i've probably left
left the door open really to members of
the committee to decide if that's what
they want to do
if i might just add i also think that
the social media
has considerably been improved and made
people are more aware of using social
media which will be
one of the forms that we use for
notification
uh no find the public on this as uh
as mr goodman said there is no budget
for this at present
and it would be a decision for full
council
but i say on the results that we
from the previous uh distribution of
leaflets across the whole district
i think i would find it personally very
difficult to justify that sort of
expenditure
for the well the inquiry or the increase
from last time was minimal i think is a
fair assessment
yes i come back yeah thank you
um chairman i think given the
current um position with
covid and still we know that some
residents are fearful about going out
and older members and i think councillor
foster
raised this during the working group
about older members of the community who
may not have access to digital means
such as social media as you've just
mentioned
i still think that this consultation
warrants the expense of letting every
single household
in the district know what about
this consultation and i do feel strongly
about that and i think
as as members of political parties when
we campaign
i think everyone in this room puts a
leaflet out why do we do that because we
know
someone could read that we don't rely on
social media
we do do that as as a method to get the
message across
and i think it would be i'll be
strong to say negligent of us not to do
that
thank you
this council in newport said i did raise
that at the working group and i do share
that concern the
feedback from the consultations before
was quite small in reality but of course
when plans come forward in due course
the feedback is massive
and i do recall reading in one of the
papers a discussion about using the
parish magazines
piggyback on that with an article from
the district council as a means of doing
that
i think i think uh council i think
there's also
mr goodwin has got quite a comprehensive
list that he's put together of how he
feels that we could cover this situation
fully
um but i think at the end of the day
it's going to be down to a
financial decision either a
recommendation from this committee to go
that
go down that route of the full council
to decide they want to go that way
but um there is no budget allocated for
it so there is
at the moment as far as i can see
because i'm wrong on this
there is no reason no way that we can
sanction that sort of proposals
but uh
yeah now just quickly as i said if we
piggybacked on the parish newsletters
which they already pay for delivery for
it will be the cost of printing an extra
page probably
is my guess
i can reach the microphone myself
thank you i'm i'm aware this is a
concern to council experience i think at
the very first meeting you said
you wanted an improvement on the first
local plan
over terms of engagement i think
in some ways it's much better we're
looking at digital much more
i still do have a concern about the
people we will
inevitably miss in the consultation
um not to know is there
is there we all know there was a court
case about the lack of consultation last
time on the web the way it went
and the rocher council didn't lose the
case
is there a risk if we don't if we could
be seen as not consulting fully if we do
not put a leaflet out is my first
concern
um the i agree about fifteen thousand
pound i think the pandemic leaflet we
did was fifteen thousand
pounds i'm not sure if anyone was on
calls but i remember that was being
quoted
um i know i've also brought this up but
i'm
just concerned about how we're gonna
measure it's all very well putting
something on
facebook or on twitter or on instagram
or on tiktok
how are we measuring whether that's been
engaged with
and i don't just mean views i mean
really engaged with if they're clicking
on links
following through items through and then
and commenting
i think it's important we understand
engagement on this
and also
you're probably well aware that i will
probably make sure everybody in
holbridge knows about this i'll probably
give leaflets to everybody in holbridge
about this so it saves
the council some money um is there could
there be an issue around
different areas have having different
sorts of engagement like that
as well um and just going back to the
social media are we i think it's very
important and i think i've raised this
before
that we have a budget for paid for ads
it doesn't have to be
thousands but i think it's important
that we we do do paid for ads
as well to make sure it gets a greater
reach and you can do those two
geographic
geographical areas quite easily i've had
a look at this over the last few months
and i think other councils have done
these before so they're the key
issues thank you good communication with
them
i'll come back on that if you like so um
yeah just to
um just to to emphasize really that yeah
absolutely promoted ads on facebook um
instagram things like that are
definitely within the kind of budget
that we
that we have allocated for this um
you know i have worked with the comms
team in the past to do that and
obviously
as you've alluded to um they can be
targeted
so you know if we were really wanting to
push them at
people of a certain age or people in a
certain location then
that is possible as far as i understand
it
the just to come back on some of the
other points raised as well i mean in
terms of
analytics for the consultation so
absolutely at the point at which people
respond they will be asked
a basic question about how they found
out about it that's at the very basic
level
but also when it comes to social media
promoted posts all the kind of things
like that
absolutely we can mine that information
and find out
um broad trends about it and that can
allow ourselves to do some
relatively primitive but probably still
fairly accurate
analysis about representation and
obviously about how people are finding
out and possibly who's not finding out
and six weeks is a fairly long time so
you know we can obviously always put
into place measures during the middle of
a consultation to try and
address any deficiencies that we do
notice
and we will as before prepare a feedback
report so
this committee will get a report in late
summer which will obviously summarize
the consultation
and obviously any trends or lessons
learned from that consultation as we did
with the issues and options
just on the point about court case and
compliance and things like that i think
the main point to emphasize on that
really is that
the most important thing is that the
count the consultation is in compliance
with the statement of community
involvement
um and you know the statement community
involvement does
bind the council to certain things but
it also gives the council
the freedom to decide um what is
appropriate in certain cases as well
so in putting together that consultation
strategy we've very much been
making sure that we are compliant with
that sci as a minimum
and obviously always also going above it
in in some cases so things like promoted
ads things like that aren't
um particularly prominent in the sci um
so in that sense you know i'm confident
that we would be
consulting completely compliantly and
obviously there's no
national requirement to consult in a
particular way other than to do with
dates
and in formats and things like that but
you know we're
confident that we would take all of
those and just on the point about the
the letters i mean the council can
obviously choose to do that but there
you know again there's no requirement in
the sci or
in national policy to send a letter to
every
household um at the moment but like i
say it's not
impossible for the council to do that it
wouldn't create an issue to do it
in terms of compliance
if information comes back
during the consultation that maybe some
people aren't being reached
how would it will that be decided by the
chairman with
with someone else or would it be decided
by the actual officers whether to
broaden the consultation at all
what well you said about feedback will
there be
quite live feedback so that either the
chairman or the committee itself can
say well we think we need to we don't
think this is not working very well
because it is going to be essentially
over the summer i understand
and i would have thought
six could we mean i know it says six
weeks but i think minimum six weeks
might be best and i understand that
there
is a statutory limit on that as well
i think i might be wrong but i believe
that
we've got this period because that meets
with criteria
and also it keeps us on the timetable
that we need to
to maintain i don't think we want to
keep extending all these
areas of progress otherwise the next
thing we'll find is that we start
drifting again into
periods that we are behind the schedule
and i think that is very
uh it was important that we maintain the
timetable that we have
set i quite agree i think we are we're
late anyway doing this
all it was was a minimum of i'm just
looking forward
who knows what's around the corner if
there's an interruption
the criteria on that area i think
we should believe that with regard to
the items that you have raised i don't
really see
how we can make a recommendation for
that
on the basis that we have no budget for
this
i would suggest that we refer to the
recommendations
on page 5.5 and that this goes to full
council as such and that you raise the
issue at full council
when the item comes up i've just checked
this with uh
with sonia and that would be perfectly
within your rights to do so
if you so desire if you want to make a
case
to full council that leaflets should be
distributed to the whole county
to the whole district
okay
yeah okay any more questions
our best thing oh sorry come here thank
you chairman um
i will start again thank you chairman
sorry chairman on item 5.53
it does state the consultation strategy
commits to and there's quite a few
bullet points there
where the other councillors have brought
up the issues about um
press release so i i feel that you know
all these
these bullet points have been answered i
don't really believe we can do anymore
unless of course we do our own
newsletters and put something in our own
newsletter
but i think you know we we've done quite
a bit of what's
you know what we're expected to do i
think uh
we've done everything that we thought we
realistically could
within this committee if full council
wishes to say something different
and all we can do is let paul council
take that view
but at the moment i think we've pretty
much
exhausted this line of conversation
um if there's no more questions we do
have
three recommendations um in section
paragraph 9.1 recommendations
if we're all in agreement we will vote
on those
with the understanding that should you
feel that you wish to raise the issue
with full council when these
these reports are submitted then you do
so
is that okay are we all in agreement
with the recommendations
members on 5.5 agree chairman i agree
on the basis of the statement of your
statement yeah
okay thank you very much moving on
mr goodman to
thank you chairman so um the statement
of community involvement
is a document that sets out
the ways in which the ways in which the
council will
involve the community um in both the
local plan but also planning
applications and also
the enforcement process so
there's a requirement in national policy
and legislation that
it is reviewed every five years and as
we adopted our last version in the
summer of 2016
we are now at that five-year window for
a review
and naturally that review has identified
quite a few areas that
um require updating um both in terms of
uh coronavirus in terms of
new practices and things like that but
also in the context
of just a few minor points um such as
you know removing the reference to facts
given
um we're no longer able to receive
comments by fax
so the changes themselves um
are made to the adopted version it's not
a whole new
document it is um a changed version of
the 26 document
and those changes have been made in
order to
meet that five-year review requirement
but also to make sure it's up-to-date
realistic and a worthwhile resource
for residents and others um
so the recommendation um is that this
similar to the previous item also goes
out for a period of public consultation
my proposal would be to twin track
the two documents um
it is worth probably saying that it's
not a legal requirement to consult on a
statement of community involvement
however
the council has done so in the past
and i consider it to be a worthwhile
exercise
a relatively cost neutral exercise to
allow the public and others an
opportunity to shape
this document particularly given um it
is
ultimately about community involvement
so
the recommendations i believe are that
it is consulted up upon for that period
of six weeks and then the
the version post consultation will be
returned to this committee
with any recommended changes um
and uh at that point it will be for the
committee to decide whether to recommend
to council that it is adopted
at this stage we're not agreeing the
wording per se we are agreeing the
wording to go out to consultation
so that's probably all i have to say on
that item chairman but if anyone has any
questions i'm more than happy to
to take them
thank you chairman just um one quick
question dan
um i noticed the um
the channels in which you can report um
planning enforcement on uh 23.
um if you want to um
report a breach of that info
one of the methods that isn't in there
is via the web chat
um on the website it says online
but it's just got the link to it how
would web
chat and those chats be
funneled into comms with the planning
team because
as we know the phones don't tend to get
answered very well at rockford and
and marcus is laughing but it is
is something that as it comes up time
and time again
and when i've spoken to the acting
managing director about it
the channel is being pushed to use the
web chat
so shouldn't the web chat be in there
somewhere
or how you're going to deal with the
process that that's going to be dealt
with
and is that a recognized way
of reporting into the council
i think possibly one of my colleagues
may want to answer this given it's to do
with enforcement
um it's not my cup of tea
thank you councillor newport it's a very
valid question
um customer services man the web chat
and then where they customer services
will then email
planning.enforcement so it gets picked
up there and that email address is on
there
so sorry just going back to this
document then
so really web chat should be in there as
a channel
for reporting that
because at the moment it's just online
vibe form
yep it says phone phone phone
host or in person doesn't say about web
chat
which is a different channel it's not
it's not using a web form yeah the chat
is a different channel
okay so that really should be included
in that document
yep well we can make those amendments
it's fine yeah i think i think because
as we know
that that's being pushed more it's worth
having in there
on the basis that we've if there's any
other questions
on the basis that we include that in the
final document presented for
council can we go along with the
recommendation in eight point one
um it's about the social media again
and we're talking about media such as
twitter that's on page
10 of 32 which is probably a different
page
different things page three of them
um we'll be using
assume this is going to be all their
channels now which i think includes
instagram and and
facebook tick tock i don't know um
i think it's useful to highlight the
ones we do do if people come before
consulting people i think we should
highlight
all of the social media outlets i
noticed that we're not
and i think that's probably
understandable to some degree that we'll
go i'm not going to accept comments
by social media i don't think you can
probably properly answer the
consultation
a consultation particularly usefully
through
twitter or instagram
i suggest facebook might be a different
point there's certainly good things to
pick up
i wouldn't um are we turning off
comments on this then is that what we're
saying or we'll be taking a note of
comments for engagement
and again i'd be this comes back to what
i was talking about
on the previous side a good sort of
they're sort of similar in many ways
about these items one follows the other
but um i think we should make a mention
of um
engaging if required in
paid media ads on this as well
you've already made that point i know
this is a different yeah
you've made the point of paid ads and i
think council goodman
mr goodman sorry has already answered
this
aspect in the earlier statement i know
but this is a different
but it's about engagement i take the
point and it's
it's
yes but one is about consultation this
is about how we go about the
consultation well
i think so i think i don't want you i
think we can ask you or discuss it all
evening
yeah so if you don't want to put it in
there that's fine i'm just saying i
think it should be in there yeah that's
it may i just
may i just quickly say on the issue of
um comments via social media so the main
reason why that's not
possible is that there's a legal
requirement both for
local plans and planning applications
that comments aren't anonymous
and that they are attached to ideally an
address
and so because social media is so
anonymized
or not it's just not possible
without kind of extensive um
dialogue with the comment lever but
that's not to say that
they can't be picked up in a more kind
of informal way to get a feel of
public feeling and things like that but
just formal representations
can't be made because of that
thank you very much chairman i think
it's important to know in this document
pages seven and eight where the
update is put in there in regards to
uh media and advertising this has now
gone in
very bearing bearing the regulation 18
and also going on to the plan stage so i
think a lot of the comments that
some members have made this evening
are actually highlighted in the document
itself
in the update so i think it does take
those things into consideration i
believe okay
thank you councilwood well on the basis
of
the one specific item that's been
highlighted
which i'm sure we can include
in the final presentation to full
council can we
agree on the recommendation
as in 8.1 on page 6.3
the statement of community involvement
2020 run
review be consulted on for a period of
six weeks with the
inclusion of the comments that we've
made are we in agreement members
yes thank you okay
moving on to agenda item number seven
thank you chairman
so the next item is the local
development scheme
so the local development scheme is a
statutory document it sets out a
timetable for plan making
and we are required to maintain an
up-to-date local development scheme to
keep people informed about progress on
the local plan
so this latest update is uh goes hand in
hand with
item number five in terms of making it
clear
the council's intention to consult on
the spatial options document
this summer as well as providing a
realistic timetable for the next stages
of plan making
so this is hopefully not completely new
members may have seen obviously project
plans that present similar information
this is a more formal document than a
project plan and we are required to keep
them
up to date um
so in that sense it is uh it is an
update um timetable to monitor our
progress against
and obviously um make any amendments
later down the line if they're required
either because of a change in approach
or because of a change in timetable
whether that's bringing things forward
um or otherwise and because it's a
statutory document there is a
requirement that this is adopted
hence the recommendation to this
committee is that it's recommended
to full council that the document at
appendix a be
adopted
okay members any questions on this
particular item
yes
yeah part of this may be my newness to
this particular
subject on the back page of the
scheme report it talks about
the subject of failure for
infrastructure to be delivered
risk low i wonder how
that assessment is arrived at
okay so um clearly through the local
plan
there's a requirement to identify the
infrastructure that's required to
deliver the strategy so we're still at a
stage where we haven't settled on that
strategy so
the infrastructure requirements are
obviously not known in detail
at this point however we are hoping to
commission
an infrastructure delivery plan
viability assessment and some other
evidence in the next couple of months
and those will start to identify the
infrastructure required
and the cost of delivering it what i
would also say is that it's obviously
important that the strategy that goes
into
the new local plan which you know is for
members to determine um
you know subsequently to this uh to this
consultation
um we'll also need to make sure that
appropriate infrastructure is delivered
to support the strategy
so the level of risk being identified as
low you know is a judgment based on
um the fact that there's you know plenty
of work planned
to make sure that that infrastructure
can be delivered
it's not that there's no risk you know
clearly there are risks around
viability of development etc
however you know i think probably all
members of this committee and
us as officers are committed to making
sure that the infrastructure is
delivered alongside the new local plan
and in that sense the low risk has been
identified
you know this can be reviewed over time
but there's nothing
in front of me right now to give me
greater concern that that would be a
medium or or higher risk
in my judgment
who can it may be appropriate at this
point to say that
well it seems that mr goodman is you
know a one-man band he isn't a one-man
band and
he has got the capabilities and the
resources to bring in
additional expertise as and when he
feels it's appropriate
to make sure this program stays on on
track
okay thank you okay
i did a course on risk today so it might
be someone's bad day
um i can't see how we can class it as
low risk
if we're saying we're not sure what the
risk is if that is that's what i
understood
was what was just said that's how it
came across to me we're not sure of the
risk at this point because we've not
done an assessment
well can i just ask what would your
assessment what would you like it to say
unknown i think i don't see how he came
a long performance i would rate it at
medium to high
on past performance well i think i think
mr cooper is our officer on this
assessment his assessment and his
professional expertise is
that the risk at this stage is low um
i'm certainly not qualified to argue
with him i don't know if anybody else
argue on a is status that uh his
assessment is wrong if that's how he
believes it to be
then as the officer of this council i
will have to support him
and as councillors we are here to raise
things we may see his issues and it's
not a
an indication of how we regard daniel
which is quite highly um i i do still
have concern so as long as my opinion is
noted
on that and and i think i think the risk
is probably higher than that
um also going on for that potential
mitigation
um consider alternative options for
delivering infrastructure including
infrastructure first approach
[Music]
i myself have written to councillor
lee scott new
cabinet member essex for highways and
infrastructure
asking if they are doing a strategic
overview of infrastructure
and transport links etc for essex and
our district in particular i've not yet
had an answer have we also
asked that or are we aware that that's
being done
well i mean we certainly yeah i mean we
certainly have regular
conversations with with them around
infrastructure requirements
um i think it's difficult at this stage
to really talk about
the infrastructure required for the new
local plan because obviously it's linked
to development that we
don't know if it's going to happen where
it's going to happen and how and how
much so it's
you know we we have a vague
understanding i suppose of the likely
levels of growth that would be needed to
support
new infrastructure and we've got a very
good understanding of
perhaps where the infrastructure isn't
working very well at the moment
but what i would say is that at this
time we don't really have any details
although you know similar to my previous
point you know i've got no
concerns at this moment in time that
we're
likely to struggle to make a good case
for infrastructure investment but i
appreciate there's
another aspect to infrastructure around
you know that that's not linked to
growth
you know that that's linked to capital
investment and everything else and
i think probably um perhaps i'm not the
person to to
to know all the details on essex county
council's capital investment but
you know certainly that link to planning
i have no
major concerns from in the context of
the new local plan at the moment
that's what i would say okay
anything else members
on page 7.2 as a recommendation
the veteran rents council and the local
development scheme 2021-23
set out an appendage pay be adopted and
published on the council's website
are we all in agreement
thank you
last but not least
thank you chairman so the last item on
the agenda
is an evidence-based document it's the
site appraisal paper
so the purpose of this document is to
undertake an initial assessment of the
sustainability of the different
sites that have been put forward to the
council as part of the
call for sites and the main purpose of
it is to
provide a kind of transparent and robust
assessment of
the performance of sites against a whole
host of criteria
which is obviously useful to inform um
interested parties whether it's
residents landowners etc
what i would emphasize is that it's not
about selecting sites
at this stage although clearly it could
evolve into a process for selecting
sites
and in that sense it doesn't weigh the
criteria against one another
and it doesn't try to form firm opinions
or conclusions around
whether certain sites are good
candidates for development or they're
not
it really is just for information and to
inform
future work i did know
at the working group meeting there were
some concerns about the clarity
of some aspects of the document
particularly around
use of color in the tables and the maps
what i would say to members is that as
explained at the working group we are
working on an interactive map and the
hope with that is that it would allow
people to
easily see the results of this paper
without having to
um strain their eyes looking on a side
of a4
and we hope that that map would be
available by the time we go out to
consultation so
in the next three to four weeks
as i said earlier there's no waiting uh
amongst the criteria and i'm sure it
could be argued that there are other
criteria that could be looked at but
we have tried to remain detailed but
proportionate in selecting criteria
obviously taking into account the amount
of information available
and the level of variation between
different sites
and in that sense they are all scored
every criteria on a scale
at the moment between uh the worst
performing and the best performing
i know i've had a suggestion about
changing that to a numerical scale
and i'm happy to for members to consider
whether or not that would be a better
way
of presenting the information i think
the the bottom line is it's about
scoring sites but it's not about
selecting sites
and i think it's quite an important
nuance
and that's emphasized in the document
okay members any questions on that go on
john
i was gone i'm sorry
thank you chairman um realistically i
would like to congratulate the officers
this is a
huge piece of work that has been
completed
and it's extremely comprehensive and
i believe that the new interactive map
uh that i i got uh samples of i think
you may
all have had some i'm not sure whether
um
mr goodman sent them out but uh it gives
a great idea of how it's actually going
to work and i
i believe it was councillor newport who
who put that question uh to the
committee
in regards to that work being done and i
think
it's going to be very useful for anybody
who actually goes
on the site to look at each individual
site to be able to have that come up
rather than coming through the whole
list
going down because it's a bit of
tiresome job but
you know i'm very grateful that the
officers have really
got stuck in to this because it's a
tough bit of work but it needs to have
absolute clarity that so that everybody
understands exactly the merits or
demerits
of every site thank you chairman thank
you
james thank you councillor ward for
recognizing my input on that um yeah
just going back to um the the tables
um and the use of
lettering over a numerical scale
i feel that a numerical scale would be
visually
a lot easier to interpret to interpret
than what we have in front of us now
also that a lot of these tables don't
have a
legend on so you have to
you keep flicking back to you know
further on back in the document
to actually understand what you're
trying to to look at so i think
i do have a strong
suggestion to the committee that we
change that to a numerical scale because
i think
one to five or one one to ten is a lot
easier to interpret
um going i know that
um during the working group meeting
there was
talk about the maps and i think
the resolution of the maps needs
greatly improving because i think that's
already been recognized but also
um i've got a thing about mapping with a
macro science degree but um
with the interactive map i took
a brief look at it today and i don't
know if you've done that in arcgis or
something like that
with layers and i think as a mapping
professional if you like that to me is
quite easy
i think we need to think that we're
putting this out to the public
to the consumer is that going to be
has it been tested across multiple
devices does it work on a mobile phone
does it work on an ipad
does it work on a desktop computer does
it work on a mac does it work on windows
has all that been tested that's a
concern
because we know if we're pushing all
this information out digitally
we're just gonna officers are gonna get
inundated with
that didn't work couldn't see it those
sorts of comments
and so it's really important that all
that sort of testing is done
prior to this going out and and
one of the things that i would have
personally done if i was
if i was producing an interactive map
and and i'm not trying to take anything
away from what you've done but
i would have probably used google
mapping more because
people are familiar with it and you can
get a street level view
um you can get satellite views
everything and
i think and i think we'll all recognize
that some people find it easy to read
maps
other people find it very difficult to
read a map and get orientation
so i think it's very important that
they're very clear with
road names and landmarks where people
can
i think you will know um chairman and
counselor ward will know
when we were stood with maps up in front
of us people
often say well i don't quite know where
that is and you know
and i think from an interactive map we
could get there
you know it just and i know it sounds
like a lot of work but it's probably
not too much more work but i would like
to see this and see what you put
together
before we say yeah that's what we're
going
i think a live demo would be good
thank you okay now that that that's
that's that's fine um
so you are right i mean it is arc gis
um what i would say is and i'm no
by no means an expert um but you know
i do plan to talk to the council's it
team who do have a specialty ngis
um and i know from you know my
amateur efforts kind of so far on that
on on
what i uh what we've been talking about
there is an awful lot of functionality
available
on that service in terms of building
a um a web app really where
you know there's a a few dozen different
functions that you can add in
and different and you can make it look
in any one of a thousand different ways
really um and i know that
um there's probably a fair amount that
can be done
in that sense to make it you know a very
intuitive
map i've got no problem with sharing
you know a demo of it with members when
the version of it's ready
um i mean that the advantage of going
down this route is obviously that we
have an existing
license as far as i know with with esri
so
it's not about going out and
commissioning or contracting
somebody to build it for us which i
probably would say
might be a fair amount more expensive um
but i'm no
no issue with having it looked at by by
members at all
um and ideally it will be ready for the
consultation in three to four weeks but
that should be
as you've kind of alluded to plenty of
time to put something together that's
that that's effective um so
probably no objection from me on that
side and you
you also said uh it's a good one that
you you considered a numerical
rating probably you know within your
within the scope there's no
big deal there i'm i'm more than happy
to change it to a numerical
range if members don't object
thank you very much um yeah but i i
actually think
the numerical ranging would come in
gradually as we go along i think that's
going to be
very necessary as we're starting to look
at the sites
um and understanding um to give us a
clear
idea of where it will rate and probably
a one to ten would be better than
probably
uh five it will give us a finite
amount within that yeah so i think i
think i think that's quite reasonable as
we move
as we progress from regulation 18 and
going across as we're looking at the
sites
it will give us a very good idea of
those sites which we are actually
feeling are more appropriate than others
and it will get a proper rating on its
deliverability and things like this
yes we go for the numerical that seems
to be the
the main consensus and and we'll leave
it to you as a good one to
implement it and can you just tidy it up
with a legend on the
on the tables as well please
yes that's fine thank you yeah thank you
okay members
well this brings us i think to the
recommendation on uh
page 8.3 the committee resolves that the
site appraisal paper set out and
appendix a be noted
there being no other business i'd like
to thank mr goodman and his team for
all the work they put in on our behalf
and the resident's behalf
thank you very much indeed and for
officers and for you members for coming
along this evening
thank you very much
i managed to hold up sneezing